[Music]
one of the most frustrating limitations
of firebase is that you can only host
one website per project well at least
that was the case until they announced
multi site hosting on August 21st which
also happens to be my birthday and this
is an awesome birthday present because
it solves many of the problems that I've
run into in the past for example I've
had situations where I need an admin
site and a public-facing site that both
share the same database and cloud
functions and I've also render the same
problem with internationalization where
I have different versions of my app for
the languages that I support in today's
video you'll learn how to solve these
problems by deploying multiple
progressive web apps to a single
firebase project if you're new here like
and subscribe and grab the full source
code from angular firebase com
in this video I'm using angular's
internationalization library to create
different builds for my app based on the
languages that I support I will cover
this in a future video but the end
result is that in your distal der you'll
have multiple builds for the different
languages for example here we have the
default English Plus Spanish and French
at this point we don't have firebase
setup so let's go ahead and do that and
see if we can get these three different
apps deployed to the same firebase
project each on their own unique URL the
first step is to make sure that we're
updated on firebase tools - version 4.2
or greater so run NPM I flag g4 global
and firebase tools at latest then run
firebase version just to double-check
that you're at 4.2 from there we'll run
firebase the net hosting just to set up
hosting in this project then instead of
the public folder we'll want to point to
the dist folder with our default app
which is just our English app in this
case we can say yes to single page app
and then we don't want to overwrite any
of our existing code running this
command gives us a firebase JSON config
file that we can use to set up our multi
site hosting
you'll notice that the hosting property
is currently an object let's highlight
it and add brackets to switch it to an
array then we'll need to add an
additional property to each hosting
object called target the target just
needs to be a unique name that we can
choose and it's used by firebase to
determine which code to deploy where for
example the English target will get
deployed from the code that lives in the
distal der for the default
now in this example we have three
different angular apps so we can just
copy and paste each object and change
out the target and the public directory
and that's all we need to do to
configure it on this end but the cool
thing about this is that we can
configure our own rules and rewrites for
each hosted URL so you might have a
multi-page application with static
content for your blog and then a highly
interactive angular app for your actual
user dashboard it just adds a ton of
flexibility to your firebase projects so
now that we have our hosting
configuration done we need to associate
the targets with an actual URL on
firebase hosting so I'm going to type
out the command firebase target call and
apply hosting and then I'll take our
English target and apply it to a hosting
resource that we've already set up on
the firebase console as you can see here
I've already configured multiple hosting
resources for my project but adding an
additional site is as easy as going to
the hosting tab and clicking add another
site and choosing a unique URL for it
and for each site you set up you can
also apply a custom domain and you can
manage the versions of the deployed site
one by one now that we have that set up
we can go back into the command line and
the final argument to our command is
just the URL that we set up on the
console in other words you're connecting
your local code and file system to the
remote firebase URL so the CLI tools
know where to deploy your code we'll
need to do that for each target and the
config and then we can just run firebase
deploy only hosting and it will deploy
all three of these apps together and
just as a side note version 4.2 of
firebase tools will also only deploy
files that have changed on your local
file system which will give you much
faster deployment on larger projects now
that that's done you can see we have
three different unique hosting URLs each
one with its own angular app deployed to
it and you can also deploy your apps
individually if only one of these builds
actually changed multi site hosting just
adds a lot more flexibility to a
firebase project especially when you
have shared resources among multiple
front-end applications which I find to
be a very very common thing in the real
world I'm gonna wrap things up there if
this video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you want to get really
good at building cross-platform apps
with firebase consider becoming a pro
member at angular firebase comm you'll
get free access to
all courses plus a whole bunch of
exclusive content thanks for watching
and I'll talk to you soon